Widespread copyright infringement is
like a generational shift of cultural
values and ignorance of existing law
similar to you know massive
experimentation with illegal drugs in
the 1960 hi i'm anthony fisher for
recent TV and i'm with stephen wit the
author of how music got free the end of
an industry the turn of the century and
the patient zero of piracy it's the
definitive history of the creative
disruption that ended the era of
recorded music as an expensive physical
commodity and brought us to the reality
we have today just even thanks so much
for joining us thanks for having me so
let's start with the mp3 itself
music couldn't become free without the
right medium to deliver it and the mp3
was kind of the Goldilocks format for
that it was high-quality enough that
most listeners couldn't tell the
difference between it and a CD and it
was small enough that it wouldn't eat up
all the space on your hard drive can you
talk a little bit about the development
of the mp3 you know the music industry
is often criticized for their
mishandling of the digital era but it's
not quite true they were the first
industry to go completely digital and
they did it in 1982 with the
introduction of the compact disc now at
that time there was a group of kind of
you know offbeat German scientists who
looked at the compact discs and said
well geez it's all digital it's all
there rather than selling physical media
why don't we just put it all on a
computer so they really had to shrink it
a lot if they were going to do that and
by 88 or 89 they actually had a working
prototype of this something that they
needed more than 90% of the information
on a compact disc and as you said was
still relatively listenable the problem
was that this was a very competitive
space and they were locked in a form at
war with someone else called the MP 2
which was actually an inferior
technology but had the backing of bigger
corporate players so in desperation they
took this thing and they posted online
on a website for public download for
free so they gave away the technology
they gave away the technology well guess
what happened bunch of teenage kids
found this and we're like shoo can you
imagine what we can do with this so
bunch of teenagers in their mom's
basement started using this to pirate
files soon enough of course people were
coming to college campus is bandwidth
was increasing very rapidly both
consumer bandwidth and then especially
in the universities and by 97 or 98
they'd moved from singles to full albums
there's the number of files existence
began to grow Brandenburg actually made
ton of money not from selling the
consumers but from selling to businesses
so he could go to Windows and say hey
you want to build an mp3 player in
Windows you got a license it from me by
99 or 2000 every single computer that's
shipped in the world with Windows
installed on it he got a cut you wrote
in the book that without the incentives
of software patent revenue no one would
have even bothered to develop the mp3
and yet the guys who created the mp3
have totally rejected the idea of piracy
on both moral and practical terms can
you talk a little bit about that
essentially hypocritical what they're
saying I'm not afraid to say that they
wouldn't like that but there's no
denying that their intellectual property
fortune is based on the greatest wave of
copyright infringement that the world
has ever seen
now I agree with some extent to their
point it costs tens of millions of
dollars and thousands upon thousands of
man-hours to develop this thing they had
to do thousands upon thousands of hours
of listening tests so people sitting
there in a sound booth with an expensive
pair of headphones on listening to the
same audio snippet pass through the
audio filter over and over and over and
over again they're famous sample that
they used many many many times was the
opening bars to Tom's diner by Suzanne
Vega that they earned their money as
well all things Brandenburg has listened
to that audio snippet upwards of 10,000
times life so you're new and someone had
to do that work and it is work it's not
the kind of thing that you do without
getting paid for it to some extent so
their point is we never would have
developed this without the you know
without the prospect of patent revenue
on the horizon maybe so you also wrote
that the music industry wouldn't license
the technology the mp3 technology
without a critical mass of mp3 players
and the electronics industry wouldn't
manufacture the players without a
critical mass of mp3s right you also
talked about how the record industry won
the Napster case they were able to shut
down the first big ubiquitous pirating
service but they lost a case called RIAA
versus diamond which essentially
legalized the mp3 player after the debut
of Napster in 99 2000 2001 you suddenly
had hundreds and hundreds of maybe
millions of these things floating around
on computers around
world and no way to easily get them off
so Napster was responsible at least
initially for making that happen and
eventually they were sued out of
existence by as you say the Recording
Industry the recording industry as you
say also filed a second lawsuit against
the earliest mp3 players and that
lawsuit they lost the judge said well I
can't tell the difference between an mp3
player at just a harddrive so really you
can't you know you can't determine who
can buy or sell these things or what
they're used for and this is crucial
because Napster existed during the
period in the late 90s when people would
just listen to their mp3s on the
computer now they could take them with
them this was critical because before
that the mp3 was still an inferior good
to the compact is the real problem was
that the mp3s on your computer as you
say were stranded you couldn't take them
to the park you couldn't DJ a party with
them you know you couldn't take them in
your car very easily so they were kind
of a stranded good what was needed
basically was something to liberate them
and I think you know where I'm going
with this in the book I compared the
widespread copyright infringement is
like a generational shift of cultural
values and ignorance of existing law
similar to you know massive
experimentation with illegal drugs in
the 1960s that's what piracy was to the
Millennial crowd if that's the case if
that analogy holds then what Apple did
was they invented the vaporizer okay
they were selling pickaxes during a gold
rush the mp3 player was what really made
these things valuable the iPod in
particular and this turned apple from a
third-rate technology player that was
130th the size of Microsoft into the
largest company on earth
one more point that's interesting there
is we live in the mobile era right
we now have like tremendous developments
in in mobile computing you can trace
what's happening today on your
smartphone back to Napster I'd like to
pivot a little into the record industry
which kind of was asleep at the wheel
had engaged in collusion against its
customers was charging $18 a CD even as
the technology was slowly becoming
obsolete you focus on Doug Morris who
was one of the big music executives had
kind of cornered the market on popular
hip-hop can you talk a little bit about
him and how much responsibility he
personally bears for not adjusting to
the realities of the changing business
so Morris was the classic record
industry guy he got the talent totally
right but he never thought about
distribution
the paradigm shift that they missed as I
put it in my book they were looking at
those racks of scopic discs at the mall
and they thought of those as inventory
but to a computer engineer they weren't
inventory they were just an array of an
efficiently stored data the computer
engineer saw it like the Germans did
there should all be on one computer with
people licensing and accessing as needed
well the record industry wouldn't let
them do that they wouldn't give them the
rights to do that no matter how many
engineers said that to them so what
happened instead is a bunch of teenagers
built it illegally underground and that
became the distribution mechanism for
music in the late 90s and early 2000s
for me the the most compelling kind of
story within a story was about Dell
Glover who was basically the most
prolific leaker of all time so these
guys who went and very early pirated the
first mp3s and put them on floppy disks
and mailed them around we're part of an
underground subculture on the internet
that goes back to the early 1980s and
this is called the wares scene or
usually just the scene and what these
guys do is they create kind of loosely
affiliated digital gangs that that
infiltrate the supply chains of the
software industry and the music and
movie industry get stuff from them and
make it out to the Internet and they
race each other to do this so
essentially they're doing it for cred
they get no money for doing this Dell
Glover was a worker at the packaging
line on a compact disc factory in North
Carolina so his job was to take the
compact discs and he was paid about $10
an hour to take the compact discs and
feed them into a shrink wrapper okay so
not the most glamorous job in the world
however what this meant was that he and
really he alone had access to the
finished discs the finished product
before it entered inventory but after it
was actually pressed over the course of
seven years
Dell and his confederates leaked 2,000
first one CDs out of the plant
comprising almost all of the hits of the
era they leaked mm daily Kanye West they
leaked you - they like Nickelback they
beat 50 cent they leaked everything as
fast as Doug Morris who had cornered the
market on rap music upstairs could sign
a band Dell Glover who also worked for
Universal Music Group would leak it if
you pirated music during this period in
the 2000s or
if you just have some music on your hard
drive and you're not really sure how it
got there it almost certainly passed
through Dell clobbers hands what do you
think of the new normal of music that's
free and ubiquitous is it moral and was
it always inevitable it was an avid they
were doomed and not because of piracy
but the the biggest risk was the
disaggregation
of the single from the album that's what
really really hurt them and they all
know it for years they've been selling
songs that nobody really wanted to hear
and that was especially true with rap
music rap music it's totally singles
driven I mean there's some good rap
albums but there's not a lot it's really
a singles format so if that's what
you're selling and the consumer has the
option to just buy one song versus 14
they will buy one song so the old A&R is
essentially obsolete he's a data analyst
now they can see exactly what people are
listening to when and how and that makes
the album essentially obsolete it makes
it dead they can no longer sell it for
the prices they used to publishing now
is facing this problem tons of books get
sold that don't get read ambitious
biographies of historical figures thomas
piketty's capital was a best-seller the
number one bestseller in the country but
the average reader probably didn't make
it past page 25 or 26
so the publishing industry is enjoying
this massive deadweight loss selling
people words that they're not gonna read
Bezos and the Kindle allows you to track
exactly what words people are reading
and this is a huge risk for the
publishing industry especially for
authors like me I'm enjoying the money
from this a lot of people buy my book or
get it as a gift and they never even
open it but I still get paid if they can
track who's reading what precisely that
would be an economic catastrophe for me
and for the publishing industry as well
and that's what happened to music okay
thanks so much for talking with Stephen
Witte the author of how music got free
the end of an industry the turn of the
century and the patient zero of piracy
for Reason TV I'm Anthony Fischer